Tổ thông viết đường năng tròm ngày 17, sau kinh bố ông sẽ quy định trong vòng 2 tuần tới, việc liệu có địa
Mỹ càng sự quân sự để hỗ trợ Ishran trong cuộc súng đồ về Iran hay không theo thực ký bảo chí nhà
trắng bà càng lài lế biết, quyết bố trên của vì tổng thống nhận phản hồi cál đồn đoàn gần đây,
về khả năng Mỹ càng kia quân sự vào cuộc súng đồ đàn dễn dạo gái gát ở Trung Đông, bà lế biết
hàng định ông trăm sẵn sàng theo đồ ở giá trong ngoại giao, nhưng không loại trừ hành động quân dẫn.
Ngoại trắng cho biết Mỹ đang giả Iran hiện chỉ cần bay tôn để hoàn thiện phục,
hạt nhân nếu có quy định chính trị trong khi đó ông một tiên ngoại trà tiên lộ,
đặc phải biệt Mỹ is tịch quy khóp và ngoại trưởng Iran đã nhiều lần định đám kể thực ký xung đột đúng phát,
sau đặc phản hành nhân dự Washington và Tehran và chưa đặt tế chiến sau năm bông.
Căng thẳng lếu tháng tại Trung Đông sau khi Ishran tình hành không quyết Iran, nhà Mỹ bà thằng sau,
khi nhiều chỉ vì vạn nhà khóp hành nhân thiệt mạng,
Iran lập tức đắp trả, ra trẻ đến nay khi hương thái trong người thêm mạng tại Iran và hàng trục người chết ở Ishran.
Nhưng dịch biến mới đang khiến tổng thống trầm cân nhóc đến phó quân sử,
nhà m zà tăng sự app, buộc Iran từ bỏ truy chính hạt nhân, trong khi Tehran khẳng lếng sẵn đà phản,
để Ishran lần tình công nhưng không từ bỏ quân lần dầu Iran niềm của mình.